Olivia: Hi, everybody. Welcome.
I'm Olivia, and I'm an executive chef here,
mostly hanging out at Oasis Cafe.
[clapping] Wait, save your applause for this
guy.
Okay. So I am thrilled.
I think most of us here are thrilled to have
David Chang here as our guest and our speaker.
He is, of course, the chef who opened Momofuku
in New York, and then followed with Ssam,
Ko, Milk.
I haven't asked him yet, but I think he had
a reaction to a four-syllable restaurant.
And so, the next three are one-syllable names
for his restaurants -- all really good and
catchy and bold, which is the kind of person
David is and the kind of cuisine that he does.
In a lot of ways, I feel like we've all been
waiting for David.
I have been.
You know, we went through decades of fusion,
and then post-fusion.
And then, all of these cuisines -- some of
which was very good, but a lot of which, I
thought were more like the people I know:
Americans I know, who go oversees for two
weeks and bring back chotskies and maybe a
burra head, which they spend a lot of money
on and they put it in their living rooms.
I felt so often I was eating off plates that
were full of chotskies of a two-week trip
that an American chef took overseas.
And I will follow that with a story that I
tell about when I was in the San Francisco
Chronicle as a writer, mostly in the food
and wine sections.
And we run through a lot of recipes.
We test them. And there are a lot of good
recipes.
But once -- and I consider my colleagues at
the Chronicle to be literate, progressive,
educated, open people -- very open to diversity.
But, when I think a local -- I forget Filipino,
or Japanese -- chef sent in his recipe for
spaghetti with meat sauce, the reaction of
my colleagues was, "What is he doing with
spaghetti and meat sauce?"
And that really disappointed me deeply, because
it's okay for you to do fusion if you go to
the East and pluck from there.
It's not okay for somebody who's not western
to try to do his version of your dish.
And so, it's -- for me, it's never been a
two-way street and a real expression of diversity.
And what we've waited for is somebody who's
here today, David.
So, he's somebody who, for me, follows what
I think is a maxim of art.
You know, as a writer, where I'm told other
writers say, "Write what you know about."
And for me, it carries into what I cook -- cook
what I know.
Cook from the flavors of my past.
So that what I do is a full expression of
the totality of who I am, past and new experiences.
And I think this is what David does so beautifully.
His recipes in the book are down to earth,
real, bold.
And I've seen him say and write, you know,
so many times that "I'm just trying to do
the best food that I can."
And I think it's also very instructive to
know that when I ask David what were his favorite
restaurants to go to when he comes to the
Bay Area?
He says he likes to hang out in the Mission
and go to all the taquerias. [laughter]
So I totally get that, and I totally love
that food myself.
And I think it's one of the best expressions
of what's happening in America with American
food.
So, I think you'll find he is really down
to earth, really honest, and his flavors and
plates and bowls speak to that.
My first introduction to David was the article
I read about him in the New Yorker.
Anybody read about him?
Where it seemed like every time you were quoted,
there was an F word.
>> [inaudible]
Olivia: Yeah, you did. You did.
But it really is how real he is and, despite
the cult following that he now has and all
the fame that he's garnered, he's just really
himself.
And I'm very, very happy to introduce you
to him.
>> [Clapping]
David Chang: How are you guys doing?
This is pretty cool going on.
I had no idea that I'd be -- one day cooking
would lead me to Google and speaking in front
of people on the Google campus.
Brought Peter Meehan and dude from the Sweeties.
[laughing]
But I was supposed to prepare something today,
but as usual, I didn't prepare anything.
Which is why I would never get a job at Google,
because they would never hire me.
Because I did terrible at -- I wasn't very
good at anything until I sort of got into
cooking.
And when I started to cook, I didn't think
that I would ever be as good as the chefs
that I worked for.
And you know, I guess a lot of it was sort
of because I played a lot of competitive golf
as a kid.
And when you're playing golf, it's you against
a golf course and a scoreboard.
So it was always checking the competition.
I'm always looking to, "How can I beat everybody?
I have to shoot such and such, whatever round."
And I think that's carried over into, you
know, the cooking career.
And long story cut short, got out of the fine
dining world, because I realize that -- I
say this a lot, and it's true.
I didn't, nor did I think that I was going
to be better than the chefs that I was working
for, whether that be chefs like Daniel Boulud
or Thomas Keller or whatnot.
I just didn't think I could ever attain that
level.
So the goal was just to open up a restaurant,
and that was it.
I sort of got out of it.
My mother was going through cancer.
There was a lot of family things going on.
And then, I think -- I wish I had a better
game plan in terms of what happened after
we opened the restaurant.
But I don't think anyone in their right mind
would have opened up a restaurant in the East
Village, 2004 that's 600 square feet.
And when we opened up, we didn't even know
if we had enough room for chairs.
We thought it might have to be standing-room
only.
And I lived, literally, above the restaurant,
and that was that.
And I never thought anything other than that.
"Let's just try to stay in business a year,
pay back the almost-$200,000 it took to open
up that restaurant, and it was really just
a test to myself.
Well, one thing led to another.
And then, what's sort of become a maxim at
our restaurant is to make mistakes.
To -- if you're going to fuck up, you know,
go big. [laughter]
And no one's made more mistakes than myself.
And I think that's how we've grown, and that's
shaped our cooking philosophy.
That's shaped how we treat our employees.
And it's how -- it started off, really, as
one -- myself and Joaquin Baca, he's recently
opened a restaurant in Brooklyn called the
Brooklyn Star.
It was just two of us.
And nobody believed in us; nobody thought
that anything would ever happen.
And we were just going to be a statistic.
We were going to be another restaurant that
was going to go out of business in under a
year, which is something like 99 percent of
all restaurants.
And somehow, we caught lightning in a bottle,
and the food got better.
We were on the verge of going out of business
very much.
You know, it was hard to learn how to run
a business.
It's hard enough to cook, but to learn how
to run a cash register, learn how to be a
manager too.
That was a very difficult process, and it
still is a difficult process to learn how
to do.
But we made every mistake you could ever make,
opening up those first few months.
And then, people started to trickle in.
But before that happened, it was sort of a
watershed moment.
It was really like, you know, we're going
to cook whatever we wanted to cook.
If we're going to go out of business, let's
just really go out of business.
All right? [Laughter]
It doesn't matter; who cares, you know?
People around the world do not care about
us.
No one in the City cares about us right now,
so let's just try to do something that is
honest and full of integrity.
And that's sort of when we started to learn
not to cook for the customer.
You know, the maxim that "the customer is
always right" -- that doesn't apply to our
restaurant.
And that's sort of the beginning of the Momofuku
culture and how we've started to run things.
Usually the customer is always wrong.
That's the way I look at it. [laughter]
The places where "the customer is always right",
they take the shotgun approach, and they're
the T.G.I. Fridays, the Cheesecake Factories.
And you know, they're there, but that's not
what we wanted to be.
And we're in New York, and there's a lot of
variety.
So we wanted to add to that variety and that
eclectic mix.
So, that led to Ssam Bar.
Noodle Bar became a success.
I don't know how, still, when I look back
on it. [laughter]
In Ssam Bar, I had this great idea, because
I was -- I became friends with Steve Ells.
He's the founder at Chipotle, and I was inspired
to do a Mexican-Asian like, burrito bar.
And we did it.
We actually made it and on the corner of 13th
Street and Second Avenue.
And I think, in the annals of New York City
restaurant history, it might go down as one
of the biggest failures of all time.
And I was almost relieved.
I think we wanted it to happen, because we
won a lot of awards.
And I was struggling with the process of,
you know -- you guys all work for Google.
You guys probably did well in school and all
that stuff.
I was never that person.
When you start out cooking -- at least when
I did -- it was because it was something that
was honest.
It was something that I could get better at.
And I could be mentored by people.
And now, it's a very different food culture.
But going back to Ssam Bar, we had won these
awards, and I think subconsciously, I wanted
us to fail, so we could get back to cooking
"not for the critics" and get away from the
spotlight.
Because in New York, it's pretty intense.
And right now, it's pretty intense.
But through that failure -- and we don't have
to go into the problems of Ssam Bar, but if
we never had that terrible idea, I wouldn't
be here today speaking to you.
And that's why I always encourage people to
make mistakes and to analyze them and to be
your harshest critic.
It was a really bad idea, but then once you
make that decision, it opens up doorways and
new variables that you would not have access
to, are suddenly available to you.
So we opened up late night to make ends meet.
And then, that late night menu became the
full-time menu.
And Ssam Bar became just a regular restaurant.
And then, we renovated it, got rid of the
last -- got rid of the burrito bar concept
completely.
Next thing you know, we're reviewed by the
New York Times.
We get two stars.
And then, we get three stars.
And it's probably the most hated restaurant,
I think, in New York City.
If I worked at another three-star restaurant
and I saw that Momofuku Ssam Bar got three
stars, I would be upset.
Because we have paper towels. We don't even
have paper towels.
We have disposable chopsticks. We have flooring
as our decor.
A big picture of John McEnroe. And that's
about it.
And disposable napkins.
And it didn't really follow the genre of what
a three-star restaurant in New York City was
about.
And then came the crazy thing like "Restaurant,
top 50".
Ssam Bar was named the 31st best restaurant
in the world.
And, you know, that's a very subjective thing
by voters and whatnot, but it really made
things surreal.
And everything has presently become more surreal
than absurd, but that's how that happened.
And then, you know, over the past five-and-a-half
years, we moved Noodle Bar to a bigger location.
So we're going to have five restaurants.
We open up in Midtown.
And then Ko was where the original Noodle
Bar was at.
And I think it was our most ambitious project.
And ambitious, not in size, but in terms of,
I guess, trying to say, "Fuck you" to everybody.
And I know of no other way to describe that,
because there were a lot of people that were
doubting us, doubting our ability at Noodle
Bar, at Ssam Bar, doubting myself.
I was doubting myself.
And we were going to open up a 12-seat restaurant.
And we had to because of the -- if you haven't
noticed, I don't really follow an outline;
I don't follow a game plan.
And usually how things work for us was out
of necessity.
And that's -- the 27-seat restaurant that
was the original Noodle Bar was doing 350
covers a day.
We were doing over $4 million in sales out
of a 600-square-foot shop.
We were doing incredibly well.
And one of the things that allowed us to make
the decisions that we continue to do is that
we didn't have any investors.
So we were allowed to dwell on our mistakes,
you know.
It's sort of -- one thing I learned in college
was, I did study a lot of religion and kaizen.
And it was the whole concept of getting better
every day.
And
Ko was an example of that.
And it was -- it's a place -- well it's 12
seats.
We don't need reservations.
We can't do 300 covers, because the place
was literally falling apart.
And we don't have enough money to really renovate
it.
So what would be the biggest and most radical
thing we could do in terms of food?
And for me, at that time, I was really -- and
I still think one of the coolest things that
could ever happen foodwise, besides actually
manipulating the food is, serving great food.
Like, the best food -- imagine the best food
in the world you've ever had coming out of
a truck, a food truck, or a little hole in
the wall.
Like, why does it have to stop?
Why do people have to set their standards
to the environment they're in?
So what we've done at Momofuku, and I'm constantly
trying to push upon people is, "Let's have
the highest standards possible."
I always say like, "Why not us?"
Why can't we have the best food in the world?
We can aspire to be that.
Why can't we have the best service in the
world?
Even though people don't expect it, we want
people to leave being like, "Fuck, that was
amazing, I can't believe that happened."
If that doesn't happen, you know, we fail.
But it's really important that all of our
employees get that notion that -- and it's
hard for cooks, because they're allergic to
anything corporate or any type of message,
unless they're getting yelled at, so.
Back to Ko -- 12-seat restaurant and no menu.
We're just going to serve you food.
Three cooks.
It was a way to pay the cooks more money.
Sort of bothers me that -- I'm very happy
that servers are getting paid what they do,
but it bothers me that cooks don't get -- they're
not allowed to in New York, or probably in
the rest of America.
Part of the tip rule, so.
Ko was born out of that process a little bit.
If the cook served the food, we were allowed
to legally pay them from the tip pool.
So cooks at Ko make a lot of money for line
cooks.
And we do 24 covers a night.
And we receive three stars in New York Times.
And I'm still blown away by this.
And the pressure of it really is intense.
Because, as a chef, and one that really respects
French culture -- The Michelin guy gave us
two Michelin stars for Ko.
And it's something that -- it was a team effort
and it always is, but it was very difficult.
And it still is difficult to sort of be like,
"Okay, we have two stars.
Like what do we do?" Like how do you improve?
If you lose it, it's the worst feeling in
the world.
So, you know, that's sort of what happened.
And we opened up Milk Bar.
And things just -- it was snowball effect,
and all these things happened.
And we sort of stayed true to our philosophy
of just trying to do things the right way.
And I say, I define integrity -- at least
when I hire cooks -- you know, you can make
a dish, and there's a thousand different ways
you can go about doing that.
But if you choose to do it the right way,
it's usually the longest and the hardest way.
And integrity, to me -- at least in the kitchen
-- is, when nobody's looking, nobody really
cares what you're doing, and you're working
on your project, and you're creating mise
en place, and that's basically you're prepping
out food.
Say, you're prepping out a dish, and you're
taking -- nobody notices, but you take the
road that is the most difficult, because you
know it's the right way.
Even though the end product -- if you take
a shortcut -- it would not be noticeable,
that's integrity to me.
When somebody chooses to do that and they're
not getting a pat on the back.
And we try to instill that in our cooks, and
we try to instill that in all of our restaurants.
So, that's how Milk Bar opened up.
Everything happened by accident.
We had a really bad landlord, who threatened
to put in a new restaurant and that would
have messed up Ssam Bar.
So we took his space.
We have an incredibly talented, pastry chef
named Christina Tosi.
And I just sort of let her do whatever she
wanted to do.
And if you ever come by New York and you're
in need of a sugar fix, yeah, be careful.
It's highly addictive stuff.
And things have moved on, and all these projects
have happened.
And I'm sort of glad that we signed a deal
in Las Vegas, and it fell through.
Well, the hotel is not going to ever probably
happen.
And we signed a deal to do a restaurant in
Midtown.
And I never thought we'd open a restaurant
in Midtown.
It's going to be called Ma Peche, and it's
going to be French/Vietnamese.
And I feel like my good friend, Tien Ho, who
I worked with for a long time ever since Cafe
Bleu, who's incredibly talented.
It's too hard in New York right now for a
young chef to open up a restaurant.
It's too cost-prohibitive.
We are fortunate enough to provide opportunities.
So I feel like everything's been done.
Like, my original goal was just to open up
that restaurant, and everything else has been
gravy ever since.
So if I can help facilitate the goals and
dreams of my friends, then that's all the
better.
And that's sort of what we're working on in
Midtown.
And it's a new project.
And I guess that's sort of what Pete helped
document in the book. And yeah.
But the funny thing is, people are like, "Why
would you want to document it?"
I have this sense of doom.
Every day I feel like everything's going to
fall apart.
And I told Pete, "Well, things are going pretty
well now, but I don't know if we'll be in
business next year, so let's just document
this and see what happens. And let it ride."
So, that's sort of how it happened.
And then, it stopped sort of March 2008.
And, you know, a lot of things have happened
since then, and we're here now.
So I never, ever would have thought that I'd
be at Google campus, talking to a bunch of
Google employees.
And realize it's a very small world.
I've met several people here that I have some
funny stories, I can't share with you guys.
[laughter] It's been a very strange trip.
I've been very lucky, but at the end of the
day, it's been about focusing on mistakes
and having the courage to just go for it,
you know.
Because I always say, "You're going to be
dead. No one's going to care what you do."
And you know, I mean, I think when you're
young enough, and if you don't have responsibilities
like supporting a family or children or wife,
you should be as selfish as possible and go
for broke.
And that's sort of how we've approached our
food, how we look at our food, and how we've
grown our business.
And that's something that is actually fearful
for me, because I don't know if we're going
to be able to continue that approach as we
get bigger.
Now we have -- we had no employees, I couldn't
hire anybody.
Nobody wanted to work with me.
And now, we're going to have over 300 employees.
So things have changed a dramatic amount for
me, and I'm just learning how to deal with
it, so.
I'm just trying to stay as grounded and humble
as possible, because all this stuff can really
screw with your head, so.
That's pretty much it.
>> [pause]
>> And so, we're live with questions on the
Q and A mic.
David Chang: By the way, you guys should know
that, in the cooking community, it's a big
joke.
Like, "We should have done better in school.
We could get a job at Google."
[Laughter] Cooking is not that glamorous.
It's not that -- it's fun, but like, there
are certain points where you're like, "Man,
I really fucked up." [laughter]
Q I'll start it off with an easy question.
My friend, Grace, is a food blogger in New
York City.
She wanted to know if your parents had to
go through the online reservation system when
they ate at Ko.
David Chang: They did.
Q And could you expand on that?
David Chang: They did. They had their opportunity
-- my friends and family.
And it's really important to me that managers
-- myself included, sous chefs, chef de cuisines,
these are all variety of management levels
-- hold themselves to a higher standard.
I never want them to be in a position where
they can take from the employees.
they can be morally compromised.
So we have, for the restaurant industry I
think, ridiculously high standards for how
things are done.
And I think that, had I cheated the system
for my parents, it wouldn't have set a good
example.
So if my parents have to do it, then everyone
else has to do it. So.
Q David, thanks so much for coming.
I think I speak for everybody.
My question is, would you ever consider opening
a restaurant in San Francisco?
Love Mission burritos, but frankly, I'm kind
of sick of eating things on the plate.
David Chang: Yeah, well I got a lot of heat
for -- a lot of trouble for -- recent comments,
but I stand by that.
You know, as a generalization, I'm learning,
you know, what I say actually gets out in
the public, which is a totally weird concept.
[laughter]
But when I said that -- and we spoke about
it last night with couple other chefs, and
I don't know if I'd open up a restaurant in
San Francisco, as much as I'd like to.
I don't know if that would happen.
I'd like to open up something because of the
produce.
I think San Francisco and California -- even
L.A -- arguably has the best produce in the
world.
You know, maybe I didn't articulate it well-enough,
and that was probably what happened.
But I just feel that I love Alice Waters,
I love what Chez Panisse has done.
I love the off-shoots of it.
And Alice is like my mom.
I have these mother figures in my life, and
she's one of them.
So it's really important.
And I know that her and Tony don't get along,
so it puts me in an awkward position.
[laughter] But she provides the ideal -- the
utopian concept -- and it's very important
that she exists and that she pushes her vision.
But, at the same time, it's been the success
of Chez Panisse.
The success of Oliveto, Zuni Cafe, and a lot
of those restaurants have been so, so strong
that I think that it's killed any other creativity.
And I just think the Bay Area almost -- outside
of the French Laundry and a handful of restaurants
-- it just promotes the status quo in terms
of what food is.
And I think that, as a city and as an area
that is as culturally diverse, ethnically
diverse -- I think the food should be representative
of that.
And that's what I meant by, "Every restaurant
is always serving figs on a plate."
Obviously that's a generalization.
It rubbed a lot of people the wrong way.
I didn't mean to offend anybody, but [laughter]
It was more like, "Hey, you guys have awesome
stuff. It's great.
You guys have enough restaurants that are
cooking with that philosophy of purity, and
it's important that those restaurants exist."
Chez Panisse, Oliveto -- these are some of
my favorite restaurants.
But why does every restaurant have to sort
of be in that family tree?
And I think that, if you don't encourage young
talent, if this city doesn't encourage progressive
cooking -- and 'progressive' doesn't have
to be modern culinary, you know, push an envelope.
It can be simple as well.
Just a variety of different things.
And that's what I was trying to say.
I love San Francisco, I love the Bay Area,
and I just I want it to have -- just like
I want America -- I just think that America,
New York in general, we can always strive
to do better.
And that's all I'll say. So.
Q Hi, David. In your talk, you mentioned a
lot about 'focusing on mistakes'.
Can you talk about some of the culinary mistakes
that you or your chefs have made that would
make interesting stories?
David Chang: Well, I can think right off the
top of my head, I was so bad in cooking school
that my partner quit cooking school. [laughter]
Yeah, it's a true story.
She owns a restaurant in New York, and she
decided to go to culinary school.
And yeah, she's like, "I refuse to."
She found out that I was going to be her level-two
partner, and she said she would rather quit
than be my partner.
That's how bad I was as a cook.
And that's the one thing about cooking.
I have this guy -- he's actually from Berkeley.
I told my guys at Ssam Bar that this guy -- he
was a cuni at Ko, and he makes blunder after
blunder after blunder.
And maybe I see a little of myself in him.
But he's just got this stubbornness about
him where he's just going to work and work
till he gets it right.
Is he the fastest cook? No.
Is he the best cook I've ever seen? No.
But, it is that sort of doggedness and this
determination to get it right where I told
everyone, I was like, "I would rather have
like, ten cooks like this guy than have like
five, super-star cooks."
Because I think building a team around people
like that is how you build a company and particularly
how you start a restaurant.
And so, yeah.
I've seen every mistake I think under the
sun.
So yeah. I've made a lot of them.
Fortunately for me, I haven't been on the
receiving end of a lot of like, missing fingers
and digits and stuff, so. Yeah.
Q Cool. You mentioned that, in the beginning,
you just really wanted to open one restaurant,
and it was you and another person actually
doing the cooking.
Now that you have like multiple restaurants
open, what percent of your time would you
say you spend managing the book of business
and the 300 people working for you?
And what percent of the time would you say
you spend actually in the kitchen and working
on your dishes?
David Chang: That's a very, very -- that question
is something I ask myself every day.
I don't spend that much time in the kitchen
anymore.
And that's something that's very difficult.
Because when you're a cook, you come in the
mornings and afternoons.
You get a piece of paper.
There's another piece of paper from your nighttime
partner.
And you write a mise en place list.
And your goal is just to prep out, cross stuff
off, until dinner service starts.
And then, you work service.
You have a good service or you have a bad
service, but you feel completed, because that
was your day.
That's how you could define yourself.
And that's still how I feel about work.
One of the reasons why I enjoy cooking so
much is because it was actually, for me, I
could quantify a good day of work.
Now, for many reasons, I'm not in the kitchen.
I'm not cooking.
For instance, like Ko, I really shouldn't
be in the hospitality business, because I'm
not that friendly to guests, I guess.
But it's also because we have open kitchens,
and it's just too much.
And my time would be better spent observing
behind the scenes and teaching the cooks,
before service starts.
And you know, becoming a manager has probably
taken up most of my time these days.
I have to cook occasionally, but I thought
that I'd be able to sort of come up with dishes
theoretically speaking.
And it just doesn't happen.
You need to work with the product, at least
for me.
And, you know, I was telling Pete, "Hopefully,
by the summer, I'll be able to get back into
the kitchen."
But part of it is, I have this weird thing
about creativity.
I just think that, for me as a cook, I just
think that you hit a point where you're not
going to get better.
You know, cooking is one of those industries
-- or at least fields -- where I just don't
think you get better as you get older.
Ideas don't come to you as easily.
Obviously, that's not the case for everyone.
But for myself, you just get bogged down with
other stuff.
So, you know, whether it's opening another
restaurant, or say, I have a family down the
road, my energies are going to be elsewhere
other than thinking about food.
And for five years straight, it was pretty
much only food, and I could just focus on
that.
And I was really supported by an incredible
team.
And it's really not just me.
I mean, I am really blessed to have an amazing
staff.
I think we have one of the best crews in New
York City. So.
And I still don't know how or why they're
still working with me, but I'm lucky for that.
Q Hi. So I was working at a three-star restaurant
in New York when Ssam got it's three stars
in the New York Times.
And I don't think we were pissed, but we were
kind of like, "What?"
David Chang: You were like, "What the fuck?"
[laughter]
Q Yeah, I guess it was like a "What the fuck?"
kind of thing.
But I think -- what you said in the beginning
was that the customers are always wrong.
And the philosophy that I was taught where
I come from is, "Customers are always right,
and then some."
But you've got too much _____ stars at Ko.
So obviously, you guys are doing something
right.
So I'd just love to hear more about your customer
service philosophies.
David Chang: That's the thing.
It's like, I like looking at things in, obviously,
a different way when people say it's a bad
idea or something is a cliche or something
is just not working.
I like to analyze it, because people aren't
looking at it.
And I think that there might be something
more to it.
I'll give you a perfect example.
And you know, Daniel Humm.
He's a chef at another management park.
But the old Noodle Bar -- customer was complaining
about pork belly in our pork buns.
And I've served enough pork belly.
I know pork belly. I know exactly what it
should look like.
And we served him.
And Daniel was actually right next to him,
and he was laughing his ass off.
He was like, "This isn't pork belly; there's
too much fat in it." And I'm just like, [laughter]
He wanted a refund, he didn't want new pork
buns, and I'm just like, "I'm sorry no."
I mean, this is what you ordered.
This actually has less fat content than most
pork bellies, so.
And he was going on and on and on, how much
he knew about pork bellies.
So I was like, "Just shut the fuck up." [laughter]
And you know, most restaurants would, obviously,
go the other way.
It worked for us at that time.
I don't know if it will continue to work for
us.
But, you know, a lot of times when we make
mistakes -- like, if we're going to make a
mistake, I want us to be aware of it, and
I want us to be two steps ahead of that.
So hopefully, we're not making mistakes.
But if we do make a mistake, like if we overcook
a piece of fish and, you know, it's objectively
proven that we fucked up, you know, whether
it be on a service end or the creation of
the dish, we'll go out of our way to make
that person -- we'll go out of our way to
make it right.
So yeah. Customer is not always right.
I mean, that's the thing.
It's like, these maxims -- these platitudes
-- they're like, Why can't they be challenged?
So. You know like, I had to attend this stupid,
corporate thing, because we're getting bigger.
[laughter]
I never thought that we'd attend -- like have
management coaches.
And I call them like a Bob and Ross office
space.
And they were like, "You don't have a mission
statement."
And I was like, "Why do we need a mission
statement?" [laughter]
And I was like, "I'm pretty sure we know what
we need to do."
But she was adamant like, "You need to have
a mission statement." [laughter]
And I was like, "But why?" And she couldn't
answer it.
Because she's like, "Every company has one."
But I was like, because -- how we go about
doing stuff or whether it's creating a dish
or coming up with a new idea, I think it's
incredibly inefficient.
It doesn't, it's not the way most people would
go about doing it. We don't.
It doesn't follow a linear path, and I'm happy
with that.
And basically, she couldn't understand that
concept, that I'm happy with this crazy, windy
line that we're following, because I think
the end product is going to be superior than
following this planned outline.
And it's a very organic, crazy process, so.
That's why we don't have a mission statement.
And then, I was just like, "We just won't.
We don't."
So you know, I don't know. So that's what
I told her.
She's like, "Well, everyone has to have a
mission statement."
I was like, "But why?" And she still didn't
answer me.
So
I don't get it.
Q Hi. So you seem to take some pretty firm
stances and have strong opinions.
And I'm just wondering, in general, related
to your industry or food, What you think's
overrated and underrated?
David Chang: In the restaurant business?
I would start with our restaurants for sure.
I think, what's underrated...
There isn't actually enough going on I think
in the American food culture to say that there's
anything underrated right now.
I think that, overall, going back to what
we were talking about in the beginning of
the conversation about figs, there isn't enough
creativity.
People aren't -- it's sort of stagnant.
We don't have people that are pushing the
envelope.
You have pockets here or there, with Wily
in New York and you know Chicago the whole
scene is sort of like that.
But it's really -- it doesn't have to always
be that type of food, and I think that is
underrated.
People may say "it's stupid" or -- I just
don't feel that it's properly understood.
And I don't think people understand -- I almost
consider it like high fashion.
People don't understand that it actually does
trickle down and changes everything.
And right now, if you speak to most people
I think in general like, America is still
a steakhouse town -- a hamburger town.
And that's a problem.
Not a problem, I just don't think that there's
anything that's underrated.
So. I don't know if I answered your question.
I confuse myself. [laughter]
Q Hi. Given the importance that you put on
creativity, how do you inspire that as a manager,
since you can't do it for all your restaurants
from the kitchen anymore?
David Chang: I am going through that process
right now.
It's very difficult.
Managing people is one of the worst things
in the world. [laughter]
You know, I guess some people.
But the thing is, I don't think people are
born with it.
Just something you learn.
You learn to deal with it.
And for a long time, I could work just on
pure rage and anger. [laughter]
And I literally could. Pete's in this.
I could work and just be in a fit of anger.
And it would last all day, and I could just
get so much done.
It was like adrenaline.
And I could sort of, you know, get people
to get -- I could move people faster, because
-- out of sheer fear. [laughter]
Maybe a little still. But it took a toll on
my health -- stress, for sure.
And I'm trying to find a better way in terms
of managing people.
Because not everyone -- I assume that everyone
has the same goals.
Maybe I should write a mission statement down.
I don't know. [laughter]
But I do assume that people have the same
goals, and recently, with the Midtown project
that we're working on, I was just like, "Why
are
we just meeting expectations?"
And it really made me upset.
And then, I'm going through this process right
now.
So I'm trying to figure it out -- how to manage
people and to have them be inspired to sort
of exceed expectations -- from a distance.
I feel like I'd be able to be more effective
with that message if I was at Midtown.
But I'm not. I'm here.
And I'm not going to be in Midtown that much
this year at all because of the growing business
and different ventures going on.
So, I got to learn quickly how to manage people
at a distance and.
Q Hi. As a long-time New Yorker and have recently
moved out here, I've sort of found that the
Silicon Valley, the South Bay, is actually
sort of bland for food.
How do we as sort of customers and consumers
make or help good food to happen?
David Chang: I think this is, again, a question
-- great question -- that was brought up
yesterday.
I disagree with the panel. I didn't voice
my opinion.
I think that a lot of it has to depend on
the cooks. The chefs.
We're the middlemen between the purveyors
and the farmers and to the customer.
And we have to take the chance.
Chefs have to take the chance.
Restaurant tours have to take a chance to
open up restaurants that will challenge your
palate -- that will please your palate, that
will at the end of the day be a good restaurant.
But a lot of that -- but, you know, you got
to meet us sort of halfway a little bit.
Because, you know, I think Rob brought up
a good example of this restaurant called Winchell
Land.
And it failed, but a lot of it -- the reason
it failed, I'm sure the biggest reason was
lack of support from the neighborhood.
Again, they didn't want to support something
that was going to be drastically different.
It didn't fit the San Francisco mold.
So, I think that -- I don't know.
I don't have that answer.
But I do know if you find -- you read the
local newspaper, and they were reviewing some
spot and some young kid is doing something
crazy or sounds wacky, go support him.
Because trust me, you're not making much money
in this business.
And to take that leap of faith and to open
up a place that is unconventional, you know,
that's the best thing you can do is support
them, so.
And be patient.
Because we're the perfect example of making
really bad food and learning how to make it
somewhat tasty now, so.
>> [pause]
Q So I'll end it up with one final question.
So what's on the plate when you cook for yourself
when you're eating at home or outside the
restaurant?
David Chang: In my refrigerator right now
I have some beer and a bottle of champagne
that I will never drink because I just won't.
I never cook for myself.
I don't even have a plate where I have nothing,
because usually I order delivery.
[laughter] It's one of the few pleasures of
living in New York is that you can get almost
anything you want delivered.
And, you know, the meal that I want to have
-- the meal that I eat the most -- and I
consider restaurants my home -- is the staff
meal.
And it's the most important meal of the day,
and it's something that I witness here today.
It's really cool that you guys have these
cafeterias.
I don't think how -- maybe you guys do fathom
how important it is that you guys have an
amazing F and B program here.
And staff meal is the most important meal
of the day.
And I tell my cooks that.
"If you're not going to spend time and love
and passion trying to make something delicious
for your peers -- for the servers and the
guy next to you -- how are you going to care
about a paying customer?" So that's why staff
meal to me is the ultimate judge of like,
how our restaurant's doing.
So for me, even though I don't cook at home,
that's what I eat usually.
>> Awesome. Well, thank you very much, that
was an amazing talk.
David Chang: Thank you very much.
>> [Clapping]